- is entitled making sense of Iraq :
walk data by
thank you because of the Cambridge
schedule I'm I if this were four months
later I'd say thanks very much to four
wonderful masters students for having
done all the work and and produced
results but I don't have results I don't
have data to show I'm afraid that will
be coming in four months or so I hope so
all they have to offer is questions
speculations challenges let me start by
talking about data centers Srikant
talked about data centers yesterday I
think he and I well we're talking about
the same thing where we're coming at it
from radically different angles it's
just as well to start off talking about
the overall shape of things that were
interested in here I've drawn the
typical data center topology this is
called the fat tree topology the little
dots around the perimeter each represent
individual servers individual machines
running code and the cyan dots closer to
the middle those represent switches
which route traffic between the hosts
all of the switches in the in this
central core will be connected to the
wider area internet so here's a data
center what what happens in them where
request comes in that suppose I log on
to Facebook I send in a request it will
be routed from the internet me to a
particular server in the data center to
a front-end web server which has the job
of processing like my query it typically
doesn't have the resources to answer it
on its own search will send it off for
example it may fire off their sub query
to the recent posts database to see what
I've done recently may send off another
query to an ad server may the an server
may then send off another query to for
example the friend graph database so
typical thing from my point of view from
the point of view of the outside it's
one request from the point of view
inside Facebook there's some rather
sophisticated code running all the way
through through loads and loads of sub
requests inside the data center come
located structure to that code here's a
different view of exactly the same thing
this is I've got time going down the at
the top we see the transaction starting
at certain point in time it fires off
the sub-query to the left-hand line the
recent posts machine standard here fires
off a query to the recent posts I've
drawn that as a slanted line there's it
takes some time between when I send my
request to that machine and when it
receives the request
so these slanted lines represent TCP
flows in the network and the vertical
lines represent just processing time of
that job so for example here I've sent a
query off to the recent post server and
in parallel without waiting for the
answer to come back I'm sending off a
query to the ad server and the ad server
then sends off another sub query and so
on this is just a another way of looking
at computer code this is really well
I'll say now this is in my opinion the
core thing that makes the social
networks interesting and challenging
there's there's the interplay between
something like this something discrete
structured something about people making
choices about how to use a system and a
physical infrastructure which it runs on
so what sorts of questions do we want to
answer in societal networks here's a
sort of question that we might be
interested in for the data center point
of view there's there's developer
operations DevOps they'll be looking at
charts about performance
they might notice there's a problem hold
on the response times have gone gone bad
what on earth is the the cause of this
did the network engineers do something
do they install the patch which changed
the way the network behaves and changes
everything
did the programmers change their code
did they push an update which which
change the way it behaves which causes
everything to go wrong is there some
part of the system which has entered a
state of instability where the machines
it starts churning it does a piece of
work it gets overruled
there's too much coming in it never has
time to finish a piece of work before it
gets to request the next one is it
because of external factors I could
change in demand or is it a we had
knock-on effect as there's some change
in this part of the system and which
changed the way that works which had a
knock-on effect to the power system I'm
interesting these are fiendishly
difficult problems to debug because it
precisely of this interplay of code and
infrastructure his is an example true
story this is this is from several years
ago this is trying to help some students
debugging a master's project that had -
a peer-to-peer code code base it was it
was for sharing information about an
interactive whiteboard it was running
perfectly happy on their computers until
suddenly it became horribly slow I only
ever became horribly slow and it was
running on the campus network not when
they were running from home and
eventually we diagnosed the problem that
was it was coming transmission algorithm
it was ended up sending a sudden cascade
12 packets at the same time when they
were at home these 12 packets they were
going over a fairly slow ADSL link so
the packets got spaced out when they're
on the campus network the 12 packers
arrived at the Reuter back-to-back the
routers did not have big enough switches
to cope with this so it locked off the
final few packets so that meant that
they receiver never received what it was
expecting so it went into it
I'm out so how on earth do you end up
deep discovering this sort of issue well
let let me give a slightly more precise
statement of a problem I'm going to
imagine that we're collecting log
messages very similar to to the log
messages that Suri can't talked about
the sorts of logs that I think it's
plausible to imagine collecting is logs
of flows logs of flows or something it's
it's it's no good trying to insert
instrumentation in the middle of the
network because those switches they have
to work in nanus I can see you'll never
have the infrastructure to make them log
fast enough it's no good asking the
programmer to instrument every single
piece of their code because it's all
they can do to keep up with all the
future requests whereas something like
logging flows is something you can make
a change in the operating system tell
the operating system start logging every
time there's a new flow starting who
started it and what machiners are going
to so you can imagine that that sort of
logging is quite easy to collect or you
can imagine it being built in as a
service by Amazon for example you could
also imagine that the programmer might
typically place in certain logging
statements every now and then so this is
the picture if we have logs of flows and
we know which process which chunk of
code generated that flow which
particular request which transaction
generated that flow plus occasional
programmer log generated messages but we
don't know the network state or the code
how do we diagnose problems just repeat
why do we not know the network searches
okayed you could say well okay Facebook
you wrote the code you and the network
sure you can debug it that's basically
not how these things work you have
someone trying to understand why on
earth the system has gone haywire you
have programmers who barely understand
what it is they're at last month let
alone what someone else on the team
wrote you have network engineers who
they're off trying to make sure that
nothing falls apart or burns so it's not
good enough to say you wrote it you
ought to understand it we need to give
people help
this is the state-of-the-art this is a
dashboard from a company called app
dynamics they were brought by Cisco a
few years ago for I think it was three
billion dollars their solution to this
logging problem
they they they process logs very similar
to the ones I described and they say to
the user the user who wants to
understand what's going on the network
you sit there and you manually annotate
every server you're interested in you
manually annotate every single type of
transaction you're interested in and
then the system just the end user is
defined buckets the system collects data
in each bucket it reports aggregates
across those buckets so I think it works
perfectly well if you're a real expert
and you know exactly what's going on
your system you know how to sit there
and spend weeks annotating exactly which
categories are on to collect data for
but it's not terribly useful so this is
a better way of stating the problem
based on logs at some intermediate level
of abstraction in a complex societal
network we want to have a system which
is capable of achieving unsupervised
learning and the things that we want to
learn about what types of codes are
running how is this particular bit of
the code influenced by that part of the
network for example that story about
sending 12 packets back to back is
influenced by certain types of switch
design and how does the network
infrastructure respond that other people
using that small buffer will surely be
interested to know hey because of this
app your traffic is going to get premier
service so right this is a slightly more
abstract way of searching the problem we
really are interested in ingesting vast
amounts of log data and getting insight
into what's going on so this is probably
a good place to say how is this
different to Srikant story recants story
he was talking about data sent he was
talking about blog now processing logs
it was talking about a small number of
events over long periods of time and
each event generated lots and lots of
messages so interesting school
factorisation I'm interested in a world
where each transaction each agent going
through the system there'll be zillions
of those all the time every single page
requests to Facebook is one of them
entities I'm interested in I'm
interested in a world where we're really
really trying to get fuzzy
characterization of what they are think
of asking what are the types of people
that's that's the sort of question I'm
interested in whereas shreekant had find
out a new broad set of events he wanted
to probe okay so I don't have answers
yet still waiting for masters students
but I have I have hunches about where
those solutions are likely to come from
so let me bring in some machine learning
I'm going to depict here a slightly
simpler version of the story the full
version of the story the code structure
I showed you before it had sending out
requests in parallel waiting for them to
come you can have yeah whatever you can
write in code that's the sort of thing
that might be happening I'm looking to
much simpler piece of code here which
works in series the request comes in
from outside to this machine sends a
request here waits for the answer sends
a request here this sends a request here
waits for the answer waits the answer
we're done so that's the sequential
version of the program and just turning
it sequential to make life a bit easier
there's no point trying to solve the
full problem in all its generality when
I haven't even got got you data to show
to show the session to this one anyway
this is just an illustration this is the
what it looked like if we you know the
four machines involved time going down
the vertical axis what I'm going to do
is I'm going to take this piece of code
and rewrite it as a sequence of state
transitions and control actions so
initial state zero
leads to an action saying send a request
to host five or in systems programming
speak fork to host five that results in
a state of computation here by state I'm
basically thinking if this is something
which captures you know the the mindset
the intentions the the current state of
program execution at a given machine so
based on the request which was sent here
to send arguments parameters to a
computation process running here and
that will induce a state of the machine
here that machine then makes a decision
saying I have finished my processing I
don't have anything else more to do I'm
going to omit the control action join
which means revert my ants who returned
my answer back to the person who
requested it and so we end up with a new
state here s2 which is the result of
joining this is just a way I'm choosing
to represent what the program is doing
this machine wasn't state s naught fired
off a request to that that machine it
ends up in a new state which is the
result of incorporating the answer from
that function so this is just a way to
take a piece of code rewrite it as a
string in a in a formal grammar and the
reason I did this is so I can use some
some quite cunning machinery by these
people because no Page and Hernandez
Lobato called a grammar variational auto
encoder so now we get on to the neural
networks this is what they were trying
to represent that it's ideas which sort
of have come out of deep learning for
natural language processing well I'll
tell you specifically the the the way
well a model for understanding this is
inspired by the way they look at it and
very much in the line with with where
deep learning people are trying to
process these sorts of datasets
is use these are the actions these are
the messages so think of this is the
string in the formal grammar I'm going
to imagine there are certain functions
here F and J corresponding to the fork
and join operators I had on the previous
slide and each one of these functions it
takes in the previous state it takes in
the current action and it emits two
things it emits a new state going to the
right and it possibly emits a dancer
we're going to ignore the answers for
most of this processing so this is
rewriting the fork and drawing
computation graph all of these are going
to be vectors in natural language
processing there talk about word
embeddings they talk about ways of
converting a word in language into a
high dimensional vector and I think of
these as vectors so these are neural
network computations multi-layer stuff
takes in a bunch of vectors outputs and
vectors it's it into another neural
network function e e stands for encoder
produces a low dimensional vector here
feeds it into a another function D which
feeds it into a playback routine here
made up of more function boxes I would
need to write down an equation I think
so
arrived emitted some of the details so
let me just repeat we're talking about
state being represented as high
dimensional vectors I'm talking about
these messages the words in my grammar
as being the actions as being embedded
into vectors and these red boxes they're
just computations parameterize by some
parameter and the overall machine
learning exercise here is you want to
train these red boxes in such a way that
the output you produce here matches the
input that you were given this is a
normal machine learning sort of tasks
you use back propagation to say I want
to written this wrong way around a this
is a typical sort of computation you'd
say you define yourself a loss function
for example here I I'm going to treat P
naught is a probability vector of a
possible actions and I want P naught to
have a high entry for the actual action
which which it's meant to produce and so
on you define a loss function which says
I want to maximize the probability of
producing the output actually saw so
this is this is an autoencoder it's
something which basically is aiming to
take a string and a formal grammar
condense it down to a very low
dimensional representation such that
that thing can be played back to
reproduce the string so back to this
picture the latent variables said that
we get in the middle
assuming that we managed to successfully
train the auto encoder Zedd is a low
dimensional vector and it encapsulates
all that matters about the code it
encapsulates the the intent you know
that the F functions how is it that a
particular machine decides to fork
requests to others it encapsulates the
experience element as well it says based
on the answer you got from a sub request
what do you do next
so in other words auto-encoders based on
this sort of sequence business give you
a way an unsupervised way to group
similar transactions and seems to me to
make sense as a basis for visualizing
understanding how these data centers
work
and it's it's these reactions so so
think when I look at a single
transaction I'm going to gather all the
log messages that describe how that
transaction was processed and I'm going
to convert them into a string and I'm
just going to say can I build a neural
network which takes the string as input
and produces the string as output while
going through a compression stage in the
middle
why am i interested in this well
basically I previously I was working on
public transport data you have train
users who maybe decide I am going to do
a commute and the commute has a bus leg
than a train leg on the train leg
consists of taking two separate trains I
also was working with taxi data each
taxi driver occasionally has but
frequently has shifts each shift they'll
do multiple rides in each ride generates
multiple GPS data points so it seems to
me this this general picture of a fork
and join style discrete structure occurs
in so many places across the cycle
networks a really common feature is that
when you're trying to when when you've
given the data set you have a data set
at a slice through this network for
example for these commuters we knew when
they tapped in and tapped out of the
system we didn't know which trains they
took we didn't know was this a commute
was this a leisure trip the taxi drivers
we didn't know what we were given a log
of ride start and end times we didn't
know when their shifts were starting or
anything like that that's the sort of
stuff that you'd you'd hope to discover
from the data and then the other
ingredient to all of this you have the
interplay between the discrete structure
of something here and an underlying
infrastructure I've been drawn on the
neural network diagram deep learning
system how to incorporate that but I'm
that bits more standard to two people
used to this sort of deep learning
modeling processes it's really the how
do you encapsulate the discrete set of
actions chosen by a user which which is
new in all of this and so when when the
question of data centers arose I thought
that was really useful trouble with
societal Network data sets is you always
got these problems about data access and
privacy and reproducibility and so on
just trying to get all the latent
variable representational the
comprehension of these things working I
think is hard enough if
working in a world of data centers we've
got the most controllable system that
you can possibly have especially if
we're working with an s3 simulators
they're a wonderful laboratory to refine
the techniques so when it comes to
actually analyzing these things for real
we can just transpose the techniques
across and the the the datasets I'd
really like to see are every time you
pay with a credit card
who are the big processors in the UK
there's let's say Barclays bank they
they seem to own about 40% of the
terminals so they have a control route
somewhere receiving something like 40%
of every single credit card transaction
debit card transaction and so you can
imagine building up an actual economic
model of what people actually do rather
than what he could economists think they
do a data-driven picture is snapshot
which attempts to encapsulate in those
latent variables the thought processes
behind what drives people to do certain
activities you know it's economic data
transactions they're not just logs it's
not I bought carrots I bought onions I
bought I've got some chicken stock it's
I am going to invite people for dinner
to do this I need to buy the ingredients
for dinner so that I need to buy the
carrots at the end so so so much of
human activity is in these hierarchical
structures where there's intent going
down as experience going up and we
basically need need the tools to work
with them properly
this this was I promised in my abstract
there'd be some data but but I was
collecting data from students there's
online grading for one of the courses so
what I get there's students that study
sessions I don't know how they think
about how they approach the study
sessions the logs I get are every time
they attempt a question every time they
submit a question as an educator you
want to know how long did they spend
working on it which questions did they
find hard which questions who I need to
rewrite and so on I thought in the
aftermath of the Cambridge analytical I
went I went shared the data I won't be
Cambridge academically it's doing this
but this is this is the actual challenge
based on blogs records at a low level of
abstraction what we'd really like to do
is we'd like to infer what's going on in
the mind of the user at the higher
levels slightly more general than what I
press for data centers but but this is I
think this is really interesting I think
it's it's it's not implausible that we
could do this there the reason I say
that is that neural network deep
learning structures like the sort I
described have been used with success in
natural language processing you feed
them a sequence of words they end up
able to reproduce the sequence of words
they end up be able to comprehend in
whatever sense a machine comprehends the
end of able to comprehend what what the
text is the only way they can possibly
do that is if they have encoded somehow
inside their connection ways some
concept of grammar it won't be a
straight top-down Chomsky I concept of
grammar but it'll you know if we can
learn how to listen to what they have
learnt they will tell us the grammar
they have learnt likewise if we can
train them on people data they'll tell
us the grammar of how it is the
different types of students are
prejudiced on questions or different
types of economic agents in a system
approach what they're doing
so this is what I think is a fascinating
fascinating class of datasets to work on
a fascinating set of challenges to try
and comprehend what's the the massive of
meaning and grammar and structure in
these datasets part of the answer will
be I suspect deep learning inspired by
natural language processing of the sort
I was describing there's so much more
straightforward bits i'm semi
straightforward bits the other the other
parts of the solution that I needed
databases which naturally talked about
this sort of hierarchical data and user
interfaces which which naturally talk
about hierarchical data basically if you
think about who processes data there's
this much data in the world which is
processed by the high priests of data at
Google and Facebook and so on and then
there's this much data which is
processed by everyday people who use
Excel who make all the decisions
everywhere and the trouble is excel in
tableau and all of its friends they're
completely and utterly wedded to flat
tabular data they're great at looking at
a single level of the hierarchy but if
you ask the most moderately interesting
questions which involve jumping up and
down you identify old trips which go
through a certain region then color code
all the GPS points from those trips
those sorts of questions
there's just nothing which which is
available to people to use another
ingredient which I think which we really
handy for working with this sort of data
I'm going to call it the selector key
engine
Synecdoche is a figure of speech it says
referring to the general by the specific
and if you think when you read a story
newspaper story by a journalist that's
what they always do they they Bradley
start off with averages they start off
with a gripping anecdote and they use
that to illustrate what's going on so
what would that look like in a machine
learning world let's say this is the
picture of my full data set and the red
dots there
pink dots which I'm afraid of early
legible on my data points the job of of
this Auto encoder is to learn a low
dimensional subspace a low dimensional
latent subspace which basically captures
all the interesting shape of the data so
now if I come to this data set and I ask
you a question tell me why are some
transactions fast and some slow chances
are well it'll be some sort of division
of the data set now how do they identify
an understand a neural network by
understanding its parameters is just a
non-starter
but this tells us a really useful way to
look at it what you should do what the
computer should be able to do we've told
it I want to distinguish these slow
transactions from fast transactions it
has discovered this through its deep
learning system it should be able to
pick out two points on each side of the
line and say look at this one
this this guy got fast service look at
this one this is very similar in many
respects we've got slow service so I
think that is a really useful tool for
trying to comprehend very rich
structured data set basically anything
that's related to human behavior is much
more easily understood when you look at
it as a narrative of individuals rather
than as aggregates and parameters thank
you
[Applause]
if you think of those low-level records
yeah I'm sure would at the level of of
strings they certainly have very low
entropy but a level of of which ones
come before which other ones yes
absolutely there must have really low
entropy because there are only a finite
number of things that happen
you know there are only ten types of
people in the world to that sort of
story
[Applause]